vice president kamal harris is on her
way down to el paso her first visit to
the southern border
after more than 90 days of running the
administration's response to the migrant
crisis
but many critics including our next
guest who live in texas
say she's avoiding the most affected
areas here with me now is rancher
stephanie chris canales
retired chief border patrol agent for
the rio grande valley
rosendo inosa and rancher whit
jones good morning to all of you good
morning good morning
stephanie i'll start with you as a
rancher how is this affecting you
oh it's it's costing us a lot of money
and
damages when they come through our
property our fences and our gates
and property left there's property left
and what are you seeing on that dirt
road in your neighborhood
we have people that drive past our house
that are picking up illegals
and then trying to head north it's a
everyday occurrence down here
wow uh chief inosa uh what
how does this affect you i know you are
with the gria rio grande valley sector
and you say this is the biggest need yet
she's going to el paso
well you know it's interesting that it
almost took 100 days for the vice
president to make it to the border but
uh
she she's showing up at the wrong
address like our representative henry
cuellar said
who's a good partner for the border
patrol and dhs as a whole down here
uh you know it use it's interesting that
many years ago
both parties were interested in securing
our border and protecting our border
and now it seems like the only party
that has any interest in trying to do
something down here is a republican
party
not to get political but uh when you've
got henrik way out of
outlier in the democratic party when he
used to be
a common voice in the democrat party uh
you can see why
there's no solution down here in sight
as long as we have
this administration taking these actions
yeah because he represents you he
represents ranchers like you wet
he is not listening to washington and
following that narrative he just wants
to do what's best for his community
whit i know you are glad she's that
she's down there what do you want to see
from her
well i'll tell you i'd like to see her
stand up and speak to americans and
especially texans
she has an opportunity now she's here
um even if it is el paso um
we uh we want to hear you know how she
plans
to um dick's you know
or how did she plan to create or what
does she feel about a robust guest
worker program and
you know what is she planning to do to
fix the legal immigration issue
how does she plan to handle the asylum
claims and
the flow of immigration i mean she has
an opportunity
to do something and people want to hear
what
her plans are what her agenda is i hope
that she takes advantage of this trip i
hope she
extends it to some other regions
of the border and i hope she
put makes good use of it um i think
americans
and like i said especially texans want
to hear what her thoughts are
well chief i know you said you're
working with an administrator an
administration that doesn't want to
solve this problem i'm sure it's making
it very difficult
thank you all so much for coming on
today wish you all the best
and chief thank you for your service
thank you for protecting these two
individuals right here those ranchers
god bless you
thank you it was a pleasure i want to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now